this video is brought to you by policy
genius if you have family members who
depend on your income you need life
insurance and that's where policy genius
comes in more on them in a
bit september the 5th 1921 it was labor
day and roscoe arbuckle was hosting a
party in a suite of the saint francis
hotel in san francisco he had every
reason to be happy patty arbuckle as he
was known had been one of the most
successful movie stars of the 1910s and
given that he had just signed another
big lucrative contract with paramount
studios all signs pointed to the 1920s
being just as profitable for the portly
performer but then one party changed
everything one woman mysteriously fell
ill and died another one laid the blame
on the actor and just like that arbuckle
found himself charged with causing her
death for the tabloids this was
journalistic dynamite as they squeezed
every little juicy detail onto their
front pages with little regard for the
truth meanwhile hollywood was concerned
with its own survival and completely
distanced itself from the once popular
actor that left fatty arbuckle fending
for himself as he became the target of
the biggest scandal in america
[Music]
roscoe conkling arbuckle was born on
march 24 1887 in the small town of smith
center kansas one of nine children to
william goodrich arbuckle and mary
gordon the family moved to santa ana
california when he was an infant right
off the bat roscoe was a larger than
life individual his reported birth
weight range from a sizeable 14 pounds
to a gargantuan 16 pounds either way he
was a big boy and his birth may have
caused health problems for his mother
which persisted until her death his
father resented him because of this but
also because he suspected that roscoe
might have been an illegitimate child
since both william and mary were small
slim people in fact you can tell the
contempt that william arbuckle had for
his child from his name alone he named
his son roscoe conklin after a prominent
republican senator even though william
arbuckle was a democrat and absolutely
despised him as you might imagine
childhood was not a happy time for
roscoe the future act we mean not the
politician at home he was shunned and
abused by his father at school he was
bullied and mocked by the other kids due
to his weight already he became known as
fatty a nickname that followed him for
the rest of his life roscoe became a shy
introvert who often turned to food for
comfort which of course trapped him in a
vicious cycle the taunts and jeers of
his schoolmates led to overeating which
made roscoe even bigger and led to more
mockery fortunately for him the young
boy soon discovered his calling the
stage whenever he found himself in front
of the spotlight that shy self-conscious
boy turned into a dedicated performer
arbuckle made his theater debut when he
was only eight years old and from then
on he knew that showbiz was the life of
him it didn't matter if it involves
singing dancing clowning or acrobatics
roscoe was surprisingly good at all of
them roscoe's mother died in 1898 when
he was 12 years old and his father
wanted to have nothing more to do with
him out on the streets the teenager
traveled to san jose where he found a
job working in a hotel thanks to his
habit of singing while working a
professional singer overheard roscoe one
day and suggested that he try out on
amateur night at a local theater this
was back when stage managers used giant
hooks to pull bad acts off the stage the
kind that you and i have only seen in
old looney tunes cartoons arbuckle
greatly feared the humiliation of
getting the hook but it worked out well
for him at night during his turn nerves
got the best of him and arbuckle left
the audience less than impressed with
the songs that he performed the dreaded
hook emerged from the left of the stage
but arbuckle tried to evade it by
jumping out of the way he ended up doing
a summers hold and landing in the
orchestra pit to the raucous laughter of
the audience he won the contest and
earned himself some appearances at a few
other theaters the following year
arbuckle became part of the pedages
theater and in 1906 he toured the
country with the vaudeville show as one
of their main attractions
[Music]
in 1908 arbuckle met and married his
first wife a singer named mint duffy by
that point he had earned some renown in
the theater world so a move to the
silver screen was only a matter of time
fatty arbuckle made his movie debut in
1909 appearing in a short titled ben's
kid in the following years he made a few
shorts with the same studio the selig
poloscope company before he moved to
keystone studios where his career kicked
off in earnest the man who founded
keystone studios max sennett was known
as the king of comedy and he built his
reputation around a series of popular
shorts featuring the side-splitting and
incompetent actics of the keystone cops
these movies proved to be the perfect
vehicle for arbuckle to display his
talent at slapstick humor and he starred
in dozens of these shorts often time
alongside silent era actress mabel
normand who also gained fame due to a
comedic chops in one of their first
projects together 1913's a noise from
the deep the duo might have made movie
history when arbuckle became the first
person to get pied in the face on camera
courtesy of normand by 1914 fatty
arbuckle was comedy royalty and he even
started directing some of his shorts he
also gave some up-and-coming actors
their big breaks including his own
nephew also john and the future comedy
legend buster keaton his personal life
wasn't doing so hot though his
relationship with his wife had become
strained due to arbuckle's heavy
drinking a habit he had picked up during
his days touring with the vaudeville
shows in 1916 he had a serious health
scare when he developed an infection on
his leg that could have required
amputation ultimately arbuckle's leg was
saved but the actor went on a crash
course to lose some weight as fast as
possible which caused a brief morphine
addiction the setbacks in his personal
life did nothing to dim arbuckle's
ever-growing stardom however in 1917 he
founded his own film company named kamik
to have some more creative control over
his shorts however just a year later he
relinquished control to buster keaton
when paramount studios made him an offer
that he couldn't refuse an unparalleled
three-year contract of a million dollars
per year okay we'll get back to today's
video in just a minute but first here's
a word from today's sponsor policy
genius look nobody likes to think about
life insurance but the reality is that
it's an important layer of protection
for many families especially for
single-income households fortunately
there's policy genius and their
award-winning policy options ranked
number one by forbes whether you've been
putting off your purchases or you just
never really thought about it policy
genius is the team that you want to
check in with this is a third-party
marketplace that works for you not for
the insurance companies so you can trust
that their licensed experts are going to
give you solid unbiased advice life
insurance premiums might seem like a
financial drain but you could save 1 300
or more per year by using policy genius
to compare life insurance policies if
you're interested head to
policygenius.com to get started in just
a few minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare
personalized quotes to find your best
price when you're ready to apply the
policy genius team will handle all of
the paperwork and scheduling for free
you could save 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius and getting covered now
locks in your rate over the course of a
10 or 20 year policy those savings
really add up and best of all eligible
applicants can get covered in as little
as a week so head to policygenius.com to
get started you'll be glad you did
because when it comes to insurance it's
nice to get it right and now back to
today's video
arbuckle may have been making big bugs
but his fat contract also came with an
increased workload as he almost always
was working on multiple movies at once
roscoe was getting a little burnt out so
when the opportunity came for a little r
r he jumped at the opportunity it was
labor day 1921 and arbuckle had planned
a three-day trip to san francisco
alongside friend and director fred
fishbach right off the bat the trip had
an inauspicious start patty thought
about canceling the whole trip after
suffering an injury to his prodigious
posterior there are several tales of how
this came about but the most popular one
claimed that arbuckle had brought his
luxurious piercero automobile to a
garage to be serviced and while waiting
he accidentally sat down on an
acid-soaked drag and suffered
second-degree burns to his buns anyway
the fish park eventually persuaded
arbuckle not to let a little mishap get
in the way of their fun so the two of
them plus actor lao sherman jumped in
roscoe's pierce arrow and headed to san
francisco where they had booked three
lavish rooms at the saint francis hotel
even though prohibition had been in
effect for over a year and a half by
that point booze was still not hard to
find especially when you were one of the
biggest movie stars in the world once
arrived at the hotel arbuckle and
company received a shipment of whiskey
and gin in anticipation of the party
that they were planning to throw on
september 5th 1921 their little shindig
was in full swing room 1220 had been
designated as the party room while
adjoining rooms 1219 and 1221 were the
sleeping quarters for arbuckle and his
two companions among the various
attendees of the festivities were 26
year old small-time actress virginia
rapp who became accompanied by her
publicist alfred semnaker and another
woman called mordelman whether or not
they were invited is uncertain but with
the booze flowing and the music playing
they soon made themselves at home at one
point rep needed to use the bathroom so
she went into room 1219 which belonged
to arbuckle and was soon followed by the
actor himself the two of them were alone
in the room for an undetermined length
of time some people say 10 minutes
others said an hour eventually though
the particles made their way inside and
found virginia rap on the bed barely
conscious and looking deathly ill the
young woman was writhing in agony
complaining of a sharp piercing pain in
her abdomen though our doctor was
summoned but unbeknownst to everyone
he'd clearly just dented a worse doctor
in the world competition because he
concluded that rap had simply had too
much to drink and burst out in hysterics
he gave us a morphine to shut her up and
moved her to another room to sleep it
off the following day arbuckle checked
out of the hotel and left san francisco
for reasons we still can't comprehend
even though rap was still ill she was
not taken to hospital but rather she was
kept in the hotel for a few more days on
a steady diet of morphine when her
condition kept getting worse she was
finally checked into hospital but by
then it was too late on september 9
virginia rap died of peritonitis an
acute infection that was caused by a
ruptured bladder but then a new question
arose what exactly caused her bladder to
rupture
[Music]
right off the bat arbuckle was suspected
to have been involved in the young
actress's death mainly this was due to
rap's companion moore darmond who kept
telling everyone who had listened that
the returned actor had sexually
assaulted rap and then caused her
bladder to rupture under the weight of
his enormous girth later we'll go over
the fact that moore delmont had numerous
charges of fraud extortion and blackmail
on her record and that she was almost
allergic to the truth but for now it
seems that her statement was enough to
convince the authorities just two days
after rap's death san francisco police
arrested roscoe arbuckle the story was
as followed at around 3 pm on the day of
the party agbockel had agreed to drive a
friend of his into town he went into his
room to get changed and found virginia
wrap on the floor of his bathroom he
picked her up and placed her on the bed
and brought her a glass of water since
arbuckle thought that the young woman
was simply drunk he went about his
business but rabb soon rolled out of bed
onto the floor and began moaning and
writhing the actor put her to bed again
and brought her a bucket of ice her
cries of anguish attracted other party
goers into the room who saw arbuckle
holding an ice cube on her stomach and
attempting to dull her pain like
arbuckle their instinct was to assume
that rap was drunk but then the actress
allegedly screamed the words that doomed
his career he did this to me and we
should stress the word allegedly here in
the days that followed delmar brought in
a doctor friend of hers to look in on
rap and specifically told him to check
for any signs of sexual assault but he
didn't find any despite this dormant
stuck to a story and police charged
arbuckle with first-degree murder the
actor had two important enemies working
against him one was san francisco
district attorney matthew brady who
immediately understood that this could
be a career-making case for him and was
determined to obtain a guilty verdict
truth apparently be damned the other was
the newspaper magnate and yellow
journalism pioneer who realized that his
tabloids could leech off this scandal
for months no detail was too divorced or
too gruesome and the truth once again
was simply a third wheel that would not
get in the way of a juicy story it was
in hearst's newspapers that the most
sensational parts of the affair took
life such as the rumor that rapp's
bladder had ruptured because she had
been violated with a champagne or a coke
bottle even today this is sometimes
mentioned despite the fact that this was
never alleged during the trials for
hearst this strategy was an unmitigated
success he later bragged that the
arbuckle case sold more copies of his
san francisco examiner than the sinking
of the lusitania which prompted the
united states to join world war one for
roscoe arbuckle the case and the
publicity surrounding it led to an
immediate fall from grace his films were
pulled from theaters and he became a
persona non-grata in hollywood there was
a genuine concern that the scandal would
bring down the entire movie industry
during the indictment hearing district
attorney matthew brady realized that the
case against starbuckle might not be as
rock solid as he hoped but he certainly
had no intention of backing down now
given how much publicity the case had
already garnered before the trial even
started his star witness was more
delmont but you didn't need to beat
columbo to realize that her story was as
phony as a three dollar bill for
starters it changed every time she said
it then during the hearing she testified
that arbuckle had dragged rap into the
room even though it had already been
established that he walked in after her
she kept insisting that the actor
sexually assaulted the victim even
though this had been proven false by the
medical examination at last but
certainly not least some letters of hers
revealed that she was plotting to extort
arbuckle for money unsurprisingly gelman
was never called to testify during the
actual trials the whole thing should
have ended right then and there but the
judge concluded that arbuckle could
still be tried for first degree murder
based on testimonies from a few other
women who attended the party who claimed
that they heard rap say he did this to
me or something of that effect at one
point brady genuinely wanted to seek the
death penalty in the case but ultimately
the charge was lessened to manslaughter
which could still result in a 10-year
sentence for the actor if he was found
guilty the first trial began on november
14th 1921 most of the medical evidence
went along the same lines the injuries
could have been caused by arbuckles
volnumana's body but they could also
have been caused by something else such
as stds cystitis or an abortion then
came the testimonies from the women who
said they heard virginia rapp accuse
arbuckle of attacking her they were
betty campbell alice blake and zay
prevon all of them actresses models or
showgirls who attended the party during
cross-examination arbuckle's defence
team showed that all three of them had
been intimidated by the prosecution to
testify against the accused if they
didn't brady would have them hit with a
perjury charge this little truth bomb
resulted in a deadlocked jury 10 to 2 in
favor of acquittal so in early december
the judge dismissed them and a second
trial was scheduled for mid-january the
evidence during this trial went even
more in arbuckle's favor day private
testified that she never heard rap say
anything and that she was pressured to
give false testimony the defense
presented medical evidence that rap
suffered from a chronic bladder
infection called cystitis which was
aggravated by alcohol things were
looking good for arbuckle but his
defense team
royally screwed the pooch when they
decided to keep their client off the
stand and not make any closing arguments
in their minds this strategy was
supposed to show confidence in how
strong their case was but it had the
opposite effect on the jury during the
first trial roscoe's affable and sincere
testimony swayed some of the jurors but
now they found his absence indicative of
guilt they deadlocked 10 to 2 again but
this time
in favor of conviction the third and
final trial began on march 13 1922 this
time arbuckle's attorneys took no
chances point by point they took every
shred of evidence against their client
and showed to the jury how it was either
inconclusive or outright false their
biggest gamble here was going after
virginia rapp's character as they
presented her as a promiscuous party
girl whom they accused of having several
back alley abortions that caused her
health problems this could have
backfired badly if the jury took
exception to them bad mouthing a dead
woman but it didn't on april 12th the
third jury went into deliberation for
just five minutes before returning with
a verdict not guilty that was not all
though as they'd prepared a statement
which said acquittal is not enough for
roscoe arbuckle we feel that a great
injustice has been done to him there was
not the slightest proof adduced to
connect him in any way with the
commission of a crime he was manly
throughout the case and told a
straightforward story which we all
believe we wish him success and hope
that the american people will take the
judgment to 14 men and women that roscoe
arbuckle is entirely innocent and free
from all blame
[Music]
in the eyes of the law fatty arbuckle
was an innocent man but that was not
good enough for hollywood his case was
one of several scandals that hit the
movie industry in the early 1920s and
studio execs were worried that all the
lurid publicity would remove the shine
from its biggest stars who were usually
seen by the general public as larger
than life figures above the problems and
temptations of us
puny mortals therefore hollywood would
need to police itself and thus the
motion pictures producers and
distributors of america was born today
known simply as the motion picture
association or mpa the head honcho was
will hayes a former politician and
postmaster general a decade later he
would become notorious for adopting the
motion picture production code aka the
hayes code which acted as the de facto
rule book on what american movies were
and were not allowed to show all the way
up until the mid-1960s but in the early
1920s his main concern was to
rehabilitate hollywood's image by
getting rid of some of its most
undesirable and immoral figures fatty
arbuckle was at the top of the list even
though he had just been found innocent
just his association with such a big
scandal was enough to get him
blacklisted from the movie industry
officially hayes lifted the band 8
months later but unofficially everybody
in hollywood knew that they couldn't
touch the actor with a 10-foot pole
arbuckle's personal life suffered as
well the trials had left him heavily in
debt he became bitter and depressed and
turned into an even bigger drinker his
first wife stood by him during the
scandal believing in his innocence but
she finally divorced him in 1925 and
although roscoe remarried that same year
to actress doris dean his second
marriage lasted only four years but his
biggest problem was finding a way to
make a living eventually arbuckle found
some acceptance in hollywood behind the
camera directing a few shorts each year
under the alias william goodrich but
these all saw limited releases and
mainly featured unknown up and coming
actors so none of them were big box
office hits it wasn't until 1932 a whole
decade after the scandal the fatty
arbuckle was welcomed back to
hollywood's bosom when warner brothers
hired him to star under his own name in
several comedy shorts that same year
arbuckle married his third wife addie
macphail on june 29 1933 with the shorts
finished warner's offered him a contract
for a feature film it was everything
that arbuckle wanted so he eagerly
signed his name on the dotted line as it
happened it was also his wedding
anniversary so that night he and daddy
and some friends went out and painted
the town red things were looking up once
more for fatty arbuckle but abruptly the
end came just like the end of this video
the 46 year old actor suffered a heart
attack in bed that night and the king of
comedy died in his sleep so i hope you
enjoyed today's video if you enjoyed
this one about a hollywood star why not
check out our video on hedy lamarr who
was a hollywood star but also kind of
invented wi-fi there's a link on the
screen right now so check that out and
thanks for watching
[Music]
you